citizens of the reject nation we are
going to watch the trailer for hocus
pocus
dos today sisters
john how are you i'm very excited i know
you grew up on hocus pocus yeah man it's
a halloween for dish
yeah i only saw it once a couple years
ago fiance introduced it to me
it is one of her favorites
so
i'll be honest
that uh i won't be honest about any
negative criticisms
to protect myself today like how did
that how'd that watch go
it is perfect beyond belief
and this trailer i know was going to be
perfect absolutely no one's worried
maybe i can drop a little hints if i
if i have a trepidation oh don't do it
or i'll text you beforehand to make sure
it's okay
yeah yeah
all righty
you be fully honest this is more your
video today let's take it away sure
[Music]
i banish thee from salem
forever
they were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting
happy 16th birthday child hey from ted
lasso
i have a gift from my favorite customers
legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her power
the black
where did you get that candle we have to
get out of here the witches will be here
any second
the book
[Music]
[Applause]
if we intend to live past sunrise we
have to steal their souls
wait
[Music]
maniac obsessed with getting revenge on
salem sounds
very bad for salem
[Music]
we should get some salt why so we taste
better when they eat us
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know
[Music]
yes we back in action where that doug
jones at nice that's doug jones i
believe so oh my god i don't believe i i
believe in the original one it would
have been oh my god
that's amazing
everyone's back it looks like a lot of
fun looks slick kind of reminded me of
uh you know when they started rebooting
like goosebumps like it's like who
doesn't have that it's that that sort of
uh kid-friendly but still kind of spooky
horror yeah it's got you know that super
spooky halloween aesthetic throughout as
it should
rightfully so i was kind of worried
about that dumb and dumber two effect
but it didn't have that for me no no no
this works it really works
yeah yeah i mean this gave me hope i
mean that honestly yeah no totally very
honestly because i mean the three of
them uh you know kathy jimmy and sarah
jessica parker and uh and uh you know
the the the the the heart bryce dallas
howard no no no come on oh bette midler
there you go the three of them look like
they haven't skipped a beat and uh i
love their rapport together like that
really feels like they
completely just muscle memory back into
the characters and yeah i mean a lot of
what's happening looks pretty akin to
the original movie you see them on a
stage at some kind of halloween party
the kids are like driving a tram trying
to get to one place or another that's
what we expected from this
yes but i feel like for the most part
this gave me you know tons of nostalgia
but not too much lurid updating like you
know you got kathy najimy riding a
hoverboard
but at least in this trailer that's like
the one thing that seemed like hey
modern and i'm glad that it's not bogged
down by that stuff because yeah i feel
like the important thing is to translate
the soul and the spirit and to make
something that does feel appropriately
halloween than the original movie you
know the the spell is tied to halloween
and the vast majority of horror movies
aren't halloween specific so i feel like
that's a nice thing to have you know to
look forward to this season and to bring
us back because this is one that i feel
like would be great for a new generation
of kids both to see this go back and
discover the original but also this
looks at least to my nostalgic eye you
know like it's gonna do some justice and
like it's gonna you know earnestly pick
up where the last film left off yeah and
i feel like there'll probably be a
little bit more self-aware humor this
time around you know like acknowledging
what the movie really is i don't even
have that joke at the very end there
with the grave like this doesn't
actually feel like six feet underground
you know and that's such that is a good
meta commentary to be had and uh what
i'm really looking forward to you know
with it being a resurrected sequel is uh
people crying woke for no stupid reason
even though the fact that uh it's three
witches
well yeah and we can't wait for people
to forget that like most of the
protagonists of the original movie were
girls and you had thackery binks and
stuff and you had the the sweet boy but
you know like that's the sisters at the
heart of it i have a feeling that this
one might be the one the one disney
movie that might have a chance at uh you
know
avoiding that because hocus pocus has
always been primarily female audience
driven yeah i mean it's it seems like
merely yeah i mean it reached a good
amount of just the youth but yeah i mean
there is a sort of female drive there
because you know you come from that
perspective both with the witches
themselves but also with the leads in
the original movie i think it's you know
it's danny and her babysitter in that
yeah uh and then yeah cute cute love
interest boy but two i mean you know it
seems like they're they're also bringing
back in all the motifs that you love you
got the book with the eye and the black
flame candle and there's even a black
cat who like thackery binks in the last
one turns back eventually and and his
soul is freed but i'm wondering if
they're gonna do
some kind of
similar parallel thing just to have
every box checked of things we need to
repeat i think one thing this trailer
actually really did something what it
did special for me was it felt genuine
and what it was setting out to do it
didn't
feel like you know i'm sure when you
green light a sequel after this much
time you're like oh cash grab see it's
like it's easy to be cynical before
going into watching a trailer like this
but there was something that felt very
sincere about what it was actually
wanting to execute and i love the
production design of it like it looks
great like it looks really well made
yeah and you don't really get those
halloween inspired films anymore unless
it is something that is more like
kid-friendly like halloween town
halloween yeah yeah another disney
classic and uh halloween town or even
that adam sandler netflix movie that uh
whatever halloween yeah like that felt
like an actual halloween film and this
has that and i feel like these actors
actresses look like they're really a
game for this oh versus
like
being oh man you guys are no you're not
stop it stop it now embarrassing
yourself not watching him do the walk
and everything and sarah jessica parker
and the splits like that was
legitimately hilarious
yeah and that's the charm is like those
three are such great character actors
and i can't wait to see them bounce off
each other like they have such a magic
chemistry and two like the movie leaves
off the original with the promise that
someday you know there's a chance they
can return so it feels like this could
have happened at any point but having it
happen so long after to me is kind of
exciting because now we get to see what
their chops are like at this stage and
you know as this might be the the
ensemble uh that sarah jessica parker
gets along with
yeah you know a bunch of dastardly
witches
why not
all right guys hocus pocus too i gotta
revisit the first one i only saw it one
time a couple years ago so you loved his
your favorite movie right it's my
favorite movie it's the best movie yeah
trust me it's the best
and it's set up here to watch
i think it's great
yeah man no yeah yeah yeah everyone who
grew up with it yeah all right okay
let's uh end this video now we've got
distant channel to look at we'll see you
guys soon